welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Thor
love and Thunder Tiger with TT's
follow-up to Thor Ragnarok that delivers
all the goat screams From Here to
Eternity let's break down all the MCU
references visual details and deeper
layers of meaning that you might have
missed in Thor for poor Gore scores gory
tour the story of War Glory lore by Korg
I'm sorry that sentence is a belay board
chore currently being written in the
comics snore I'm done I promise now the
best way to support us at new rockstars
is to check out our latest Thor inspired
shirt at newrockstarsmerge.com the film
opens on cracked desert sand as the
shadow of Gore not yet the god Butcher
and his daughter trunched through the
unforgiving sun now this daughter is
actually played by India rose Hemsworth
Chris Hemsworth's daughter just a little
tease of her Destiny as Thor's Adopt A
Daughter by the end of this movie
revealed to be an adaptation of the
Marvel Cosmic entity of love it's just
so clever to open this movie with Gore
we think but really introduce here the
love of the love and Thunder title but
also this prologue establishes the
film's deeper question of can God's love
is love unique to Mortals as love
requires sacrifice humility a simplistic
Outlook that normally eludes Immortals
but also the question is love a gift
from the gods and if so what would it
take for the gods to appreciate love
themselves because if God's let so many
terrible things happen are those Gods
really loving or even capable of Love
Now the villain of Gore the god butcher
was introduced in Jason Aaron's God of
Thunder Comics Gore began as a starving
being on an unknown harsh Planet whose
mate and children all die off his
prayers go unanswered by the gods
leading them to be exiled by his
superstitious Community for when he
turns atheistic until two Gods crash
land right near him one possessing all
black the Necker sword which Gore then
uses to begin his de-icidal Killing
Spree all black in the comics was a
weapon of null the Symbiote deity who
used all black to decapitate the
celestial that became nowhere all black
fuses with the bearer's arm and becomes
part of him sort of the way the Symbiote
does however here in the films since
Sony owns the film rights to the
Symbiotes they simply just call this
weapon the necrosword leaving out that
whole symbiote backstory opting instead
to make this broadsword give one entry
to the shadow realm now Gore's
appearance has been changed Christian
Bale is not yet desaturated and they let
him keep his nose taikumotiti admitted
that making him noseless would look too
much like Voldemort from the Harry
Potter films now I like how all of this
opens in the Arid desert and Elemental
contrast to the film's destination the
realm of Eternity is seen as endless
water and the final shot of this movie
is on a beach Gore's daughter finally
reaching the water that they sought for
so long but notice how here the only
element they get is sunlight which is
ironic because Gore has been praying to
a son deity and now too much sun has
ruined him and it's also fitting that
our very first shot of Gore is his
shadow as his possession of the neck
Resort will give him access to the
shadow realm Gore's daughter says only
two words in this opening prologue I'm
tired and she dies leaving behind some
paintings she made on a boulder these
paintings praising the sun deity that
they pray to gore finds an insane mainly
flowery Lush Oasis clearly planted there
by that beloved sun god whom he calls
the bringer of light this is rapu played
by Johnny Brew New Zealand actor
comedian and Taiko atiti's co-star from
the film version of what we do in the
shadows but this God Mott score and
brags about slain an unnamed foe another
deity with an Inky black corpse previous
bearer of the Necker sword this guy
might be Ka the warlord of the Shadow
realm when the shadow realm was
introduced in the 1960s Strange Tales
comic issue Ka was able to command
living shadows as Warriors as Gore does
in this film and Gore hears the voice
from the necrosword
eternity
and he sees a vision of Eternity itself
so eternity is a Marvel Cosmic entity
the living embodiment of the universe
itself depicted as a cloaked silhouette
filled with stars and planets actually
before this there was a moment according
to the Galaxy Vol 2 when Star-Lord says
[Music]
and while James Gunna said quill wasn't
really seeing capital E eternity there
his trance-like state does look a lot
like what Gore goes through here in
addition to seeing the face of Eternity
he does see the imprint of the bifrost
as he turned his heart just a little
clue that the bifrost is a mechanism by
which they're able to access eternity so
Gore now wields the necrosword and stabs
rapu through the head and he bleeds gold
a color bled by many from omnipotent
City and his body disintegrates into
gold dust the same thing that happens to
Odin's body as he dies in Ragnarok and
now that Gore is Tethered to the shadow
realm he turns monochromatic color
playing a very important role in this
movie because Shadow as the absence of
light contains fewer colors in the
Spectrum a visual opposite to the
bifrost the Rainbow Bridge so we have
Shadow no color versus rainbow all the
colors and Gore vows oh God then over
the Marvel Studios title guard Michael
jokino's Fanfare music is actually
played by your guitar instead of an
orchestra this time among the updates to
the MCU title card the other characters
who appear within the letters Moon
Knight appears in the m and Ms Marvel
Kamala Khan appears and they are it's
her final look presumably from the
finale episode that episode hasn't even
come out yet Korg narrates to the
indigarian children the story of Thor
odinson this Legend really forming the
framing device of this entire film it's
set to Only Time by Enya flashback show
baby Thor in a Bjorn on friga's chest
mid-battle thorbjorn it really tempting
me with this rhyming scheme here this
baby carries a little wooden mjolnir and
this actor is named Cameron chapek and I
am wondering if he might be one of the
grandkids of Disney CEO Bob chapik just
because every kid in this movie is
someone's kid then we see this coming of
age Montage showing Thor running through
the trees which reminds me a lot of
Simba's aging Montage during the yakuna
Matata song and I gotta say all the
running the wandering the Trekker hats
of this movie make this film an
interesting companion watch to Forrest
Gump also a story about a Wanderer who's
a not the brightest guy who goes on a
series of Adventures including through
war and on boats until he reunites with
his loved one a dying woman and ends the
film a single father looking after a
young kid but back here during this
Montage the youngest version of Thor is
a cameo by one of Hemsworth's Sons
Tristan so along with his daughter India
rose this surely is a family film fun
fact their mom Elsa Pataki cameo in the
post-credits scene of Thor the Dark
World as the Jane Foster stand-in whom
Hemsworth kissed in the post-credits
scene Elsa actually cameos in this movie
she is the wolf woman that Thor hooks up
with I also like how young adult Thor
wears the classic bright blue pants and
yellow boots that Thor wears in the 60s
and 70s Comics Korg recounts Thor's
Adventures on a pirate ship as a kraken
swallows another ship in the background
all this perhaps and not detective TT's
other 2022 title HBO's our flag means
death and amazing show what TJ also said
that he envisioned this film as a Mills
and Boone romance novel covers that
would often feature this kind of imagery
with a beautiful couple and a hero with
its chest exposed as they kiss on the
deck of a ship this pirate woman is
played by Zia Kelly who is also Natalie
Portman stunt for performer in this film
Korg also explained how Thor hooked up
with a wolf woman on the back of a giant
wolf all three howling at a full moon
this large wolf might be connected to
Fenris the giant wolf enforcer of hella
in Ragnarok we see flashbacks from shots
in the 2011 Thor 2013's Dark World in a
hint at their breakup as Jane slaps Thor
in the face and then we pick back up
with Thor's weight gain and Avengers end
game and team up with the Guardians of
the Galaxy at the end of that film
leading to this full team up shot
showing them walking out of the fire see
mantis rocket craglin now wearing
yandu's fin after Guardians Volume 2
Peter Quill Star-Lord and Thor in the
middle nebula Groot and Drax who is
somehow visible here Thor is still in
his heavy armor and braided Viking beard
from the in-game final battle but Thor
loses weight by doing battle ropes with
chains on a giant skeleton we don't get
an answer to who this was but it might
be one of eachery's people you'll notice
how Thor wears his trucker hat which
originally said The Avengers Thor
Ant-Man Hulk and Iron Man but he crossed
out the the and the S and then wrote
strongest over all the other names
except his own name so that it now reads
or strongest Avenger which itself is a
callback to the bit in Ragnarok
strongest Avenger access denied
strongest Avenger access denied voice
activation required Banner welcome
strongest Avenger oh what an overall
Thor's look with the hat in addition to
reminding me of Forrest Gump combined
with his later look in the tank top
seems inspired by Vincent D'Onofrio in
Adventures in Babysitting when the girl
thought Dawson the auto worker was Thor
we find Thor meditating beneath this
tree on his war-torn Planet he has
planted Stormbreaker and when he
unearths it fresh Roots come up with the
handle because remember stormbreaker's
handle was made of groot's arm and Groot
has proven that he can regenerate from a
single Splinter when it is replanted so
Stormbreaker might have actually been in
the process of turning into a new tree
until four violently uprooted it Thor
rides down into the battle riding
Stormbreaker like a broomstick which is
actually a callback to korg's line and
Ragnarok
no I didn't ride there the hammer are
you on your back no no I I used to spin
it really fast and it would it would
pull me off oh my God Emma pulled you
off then Thor greets the locals as you
know we used to live in a peaceful lost
but in our gods were murdered murdered
and now our sacred Temple has been left
unguarded in hoku's Resorts the control
of its power it is our most sacred
Shrine and it desecrates not for long
yes their gods were of course murdered
by Gore despite Thor promising to save
this sacred Shine by the end of the
battle he further desecrates it when it
collapses just another example of the
Gods of this universe really being
incapable of love now yes the tribe
against defending are the same people
cork was narrating to in the opening
story The indigarians presumably named
for their Indigo Hue they are led by
King yakan played by Australian Actor
Stephen Curry and the Raiders are
bird-like psychos led by habuska the
horrible played by Bobby Holland Hansen
Chris Hemsworth's longtime stunt actor
and all these Marvel films as well as
the extraction films Thor's outfit
beneath his robe is inspired by Kurt
Russell's look in big trouble little
China Kurt Russell of course playing
Peter Quill's father ego and Thor's
white tank top shows the depiction of
the nine Realms in the idrisil the
world's no behind the branches of it you
can see the pattern imprint made by the
bifrost same marking from Gore's Vision
that showed the heart of Eternity just
another clue pointed to the bipross
being the key that unlocks that gate
Thor also wears a red vest jacket which
looks like a modded version of Peter
Quill's ravager's jacket that Thor has
be dazzled Thor fights these Raiders
raining down on them in a wide shot
recalling Thor's God of Thunder Power Up
in Ragnarok when he rained down hella's
Army on the bridge battle and Thor
wedges between two chariots making a
Jean-Claude Van Damme post meanwhile
Jane Foster gets an MRI scan and
undergoes some chemo treatment this
movie adapting Jason Aaron's Mighty Thor
storyline in which Jane Foster gets
cancer before she Powers up into the
Mighty Thor gets in next door reads a
book Jane Foster theory of space and
time and she explains to him Einstein
grows and bridges AKA wormholes
something she geeked out about in the
2011 film and here references the
folding piece of paper and pencil poking
through it analogy from Christopher
Nolan's movie Interstellar Jane also
mentions sci-fi horror Event Horizon
which stars long time with Titi
collaborator Sam Neil also appears in
this film and in Ragnarok as a stage
actor who plays Odin Darcy shows up
bring her some snacks this is the first
we've seen Darcy since one division now
notice how while Jane has her sleeves
rolled up to get the treatment here
these early shots deliberately frame out
Natalie Portman's arms since she got
pretty toned for this movie and they
wanted to save her bulked up appearance
until after her transformation Jane also
video chats with Dr Eric Selvig her
colleague from the earlier films who has
also recently referenced for his
research and Alternate dimensions in Ms
Marvel selvic tells Jane his attempts to
do immunotherapy on her blood have
failed so Jane heads to new Asgard which
now under valkyrie's leadership has
evolved into a commercialized tourist
economy we see an Asgard themed Old
Spice commercial there's also an ice
cream parlor called Infinity cones in
the shape of thanos's Gauntlet in the
port are cruise liners one of which is
painted with the face of volstag one of
Thor's Warriors 3 who died in Ragnarok
also in the town there is a Simonson
street named after Thor writer Walt
Simonson who actually Cameo as an
Asgardian in the 2011 Thor film so he
may actually be in his Guardian that
they named to Street after there's also
an Aaron Avenue named after Jason Aaron
now remember in Ragnarok Loki as Odin
watched a play re-staging the events of
the previous film Thor the Dark World
and now this Theater Company restages
the events of Ragnarok Odin's death and
hella's arrival and destruction of
Milner Matt Damon returns as the actor
who plays Loki Chris Hemsworth's brother
Luke Hemsworth Returns His Thor and Sam
Neal returns as the Odin actor Melissa
McCarthy Cameo says hella her real-life
husband and comedy partner Ben Falcone
also cameos as the stage manager that
you see when they do the curtain call
the broken shards of mjolnir remained on
the mound of turf where hella left them
it's now encased in glass on a pedestal
for tourists to witness this means that
the hell of fight occurred right in this
spot and the fact that no one can move
even these broken shards mean that they
still possess Odin's original magic
charm a charm that was later updated by
Thor to protect Jane which is why these
broken pieces now move for her now the
tour guide is actor Daly Pearson who
played Daryl and Taiko atiti's team Thor
short films that came out on the Civil
War Blu-ray since then they were
considered non-canon but I don't know
with Daryl here I'm just gonna assume
they're Canon now the production
actually shot us scene for Jane's power
up moment but apparently was left out of
the Final Cut presumably to make Jane's
new form more of a reveal the people
whom Thor saved reward him with
screaming goats named tooth grinder and
tooth gnasher these are based on Thor's
goats in Norse mythology Tom Green Anton
Yost they're given alternate looks one
light bird with simple horns one dark
bird with spiraled horns as these goats
wrecked the Benetar the Guardians bring
up hundreds of distress calls that they
have received their 3D star map shows
the Galaxy divided into red highlighted
jigsaw sectors which might display the
political boundaries of rival Empires
like the cree the squirrel the
zandarians something we might learn more
about in the Marvels or Guardians volume
3. now there actually was going to be
more in this movie for Gore's Killing
Spree because Christian Bale talked
about shooting scenes with Peter didn't
and Jeff Goldblum suggesting Gore would
have killed itri and the Grand Master
but those scenes were removed and
actress Selena Headey actually got some
legal drama over payments for a role in
this movie suggesting she also would
have played some other guy that Gore
murdered the distress calls show Gore's
various victims including Gods hanging
from the Gallows imagery evoking Assad
remix art of crucified gods and Jason
Aaron's God of Thunder storyline another
distress call shows a severed head that
is just left on the ground and Korg
gasps the horror referencing Colonel
Kurtz in Apocalypse Now Thor recognizes
one of the distressed calls coming from
Lady Sif and he Parts ways with the
Guardians human handshake
she has Guardian Shake
into the snake but you cannot trust yes
Thor is calling back his Loki snake
story from Ragnarok he transformed
himself into a snake and he knows that I
love snakes so I went to pick up the
snake to admire it and he transformed
back into himself and he was like yeah
it's me and he stabbed me now not all of
us can have the physique of Thor and all
of his Rivals but gentlemen there is
power and strength in having nice skin
we can do our best to match Thor's nice
clear complexion leave those dark
circles under the eyes to gore the fine
folks of geology have some great
skincare products that you're going to
love geology is the nine time
award-winning men's skincare company
that creates simple effective
personalized skincare products for men
just click the link in the video's
description and take a 30 second quiz
tell them about your skin and their team
of dermatologists will design a regimen
just for you that ships directly to your
door their products are great for
whatever you're worried about acne dark
eye circles wrinkles they send you a
30-day trial set that's easy to
incorporate into your routine whether
you're new to skincare or a seasoned
expert so here's what they sent me I got
some everyday face wash pretty
straightforward and simple and then
here's what I like to call sunrise and
sunset a little morning kiss and a
little lullaby vital morning face cream
and repairing night cream and then if
your eyes aren't feeling too great and
just got some nourishing eye cream it's
the Four Horsemen of fun and I'm so
grateful to them talking with the rest
of the new rockstars team they're just
big fans of the fancy eye cream our
hosts might be up late to pump out
content but they don't look like it
thanks to this cream geology makes it
easy to take care of your skin no need
to become an amateur dermatologist
they're offering a crazy deal right now
you can get 70 off on their 30 day five
piece trial kit head on over to
geology.com for 70 off on your 30-day
trial when you use the code of rockstars
70 or just click the link below that's
geology.com promo code rockstars 70 to
save 70 off your 30-day trial so Thor
Corrigan the goats use Stormbreaker to
buy Frost over to Lady stiff's planet
where we see the aftermath of a battle
including the corpse of falgar the
Behemoth Fading Into golden dust the
country here taken directly from Rubik's
comic art down to the details of the
blood trickling from thalagar's nose and
they find Lady ziff as she prepares to
enter Valhalla teasing the Norse
afterlife realm that Jane and Heimdall
are in in the post-credit scene but it
reminds us that in order to enter
Valhalla one must die in battle but that
says severed arm might be in Valhalla
Valhalla actually gets mentioned at
least half a dozen times throughout this
film or mentions I think than any other
of the MCU films combined all this is to
set up the final scene where Jane meets
Heimdall in Valhalla Jaime Alexander was
absent from Thor Ragnarok which is why
she wasn't killed by hella but a form of
her did appear in Loki in a mental
torture room in the TDA Gore arrives to
new Asgard at night moving in and out of
the Shadows Shadows that move on their
own creeping along the ground looking a
lot like the Demonic Shadows that we saw
in 1990s ghost a movie that you know a
lot of people sleep on but like this
movie is a fascinating supernatural
horror tragic comedy I'm telling you in
addition to watching this movie this
weekend you should also go home and
watch Forrest Gump and ghost you're
welcome I just give you an awesome
weekend the children of Asgard actually
includes several of the star's children
Sasha Hemsworth and then Tay and Mateo
watiti Natalie Portman's children aleph
and Amala and Christian Bale's son Rex
the shadow beasts attack and they
actually look a lot like the black
Berserkers that are controlled by Gore
in the comics Valkyrie rides in her
Pegasus from endgame into the fight and
Thor helps out until he hears the
familiar metallic hum of mjolnir boy
[Music]
oh
really
[Music]
tomorrow
I love the detail on mjolnir bursting
out of this creature its eyes bulging
out and despite the exclusion of Jane's
power up I really like how they shot her
reveal here they delayed the reveal of
Jane by keeping our eyes focused on
mjolnir itself which in many ways is an
equally unusual return for Thor in this
moment notice how we start with the
weapon going into her hand and then it
goes down to focus on her eyes and
Natalie Portman's face is covered here
and then we move further down so that we
can see her bulky arms so this just
allows Jane to be her badass self as she
swings into action
foreign
[Music]
yeah she starts by swinging the hammer
from its strap which is how cap
initially charges up the hammer before
hitting Thanos when he wield it in an
end game and here we get a close-up of
the Hammer's disc plate with the runes
that translate to he who wields this
Hammer commands the lightning and the
storm The Broken Pieces whiz past Thor
stands before the black raven Tavern
anata Odin's Ravens from Norse mythology
in the earlier Thor films they actually
mentioned Raven mail a few times
throughout this film Ravens being how
they send messages to each other they're
very archaic version of email also
something was referenced in the team
Thor shorts Valkyrie later says her
medians could have been Raven male like
the this meeting could have been an
email Meme and it's just so satisfying
to see these broken shards click back
into place perfectly like the Shrine of
the silver monkey in the first go and
broken mjolnir is just the perfect
metaphor for Jane herself someone who is
in an imperfect physical state but whose
Brokenness actually makes her stronger
so we flash back to Thor in Jane's
relationship which unfolded in the
background between Thor the Dark World
and Age of Ultron in the couple years
after when Thor was on and off world
during that period thorless Nick Fury on
his phone as Nick Fury which is a
callback to a joke in the team Thor
shorts Fury what does he really know and
is Fury his real name or is it actually
pronounced furry I love it the way mid
Guardians cannot pronounce mjolnir
asgardians cannot pronounce things like
Nick Fury and Jane Foster and also based
on what we've seen from Secret Invasion
Fury is looking pretty furry we see a
Halloween party where Thor dresses up as
a hot dog while Jane dresses up as Kane
from Alien with a chest burster I
actually dressed up just like that one
year for Halloween we learned Thor asked
mjolnir to always protect Jane and we
see Odin's symbol fading up on that
hammer showing how Odin's worthiness
charm extended to include Jane from that
moment on all this is said to Abbas Our
Last Summer this Montage showing Jane
and Thor drifting apart sitting further
and further apart on the sofa that came
to the classic marriage montage and
Citizen Kane where Kane and his wife sit
further and further apart at the dinner
table as the years go by gory uses
Shadows to kidnap the children of Asgard
any Retreats Thor and Jane catch up so
they broke up before Ragnarok in 2017
the present MCU years understood to be
2025 which is why Thor says it's been
eight years seven months eight years
seven months and six days give or take
however the endgame screenplay listed
Jane among the blip victims which might
be why to her it only seems like three
or four years the parents of adsgard are
panicking you see valkyrie's PJs
included a Phantom of the Opera shirt
which seems a bit random I don't know
the Phantom Wars the half mask does look
a lot like the way eternity is half-mast
in its statue form in its moment Thor
only has eyes for Jane the old
ex-girlfriend Jody Foster yeah Korg
never gets her name right either he
called her Jane Fonda earlier and as
Thor tries to snatch meal near back
Stormbreaker gets jealous jealous
Stormbreaker is like my favorite
character in this movie now you'll
notice Natalie Portman is framed in all
of these scenes to look taller than she
actually is especially when you see her
beside Tessa Thompson because those two
actresses are roughly the same height
Kevin feige confirmed that making
Portman taller is the only VFX they had
to do to her one parent in this room
shouts half our soldiers are always dead
I love this line because it calls back
how the asgardians have lost a lot like
when they fled Asgard and Ragnarok and
then after that they lost another half
of them when thanos's forces called them
to steal the space stone at the
beginning of infinity war and then we
didn't see them after that point but
when Thanos snapped his fingers another
half of them were snapped away so at
this point they asked Guardians are down
to like 12 and a half percent of what
they were I like how Meek takes minutes
dressed as a classic clerical worker her
blade extension swapped out for a dry
erase marker now one of these kidnapped
kids is heimdahl's son Astrid who says
that his name is Axel named himself
after Axel Rose of Guns and Roses
actually earlier in the movie we saw a
poster in Axel's room for the Guns and
Roses album Appetite for Destruction and
he wore a shirt for the Guns and Roses
use your Illusion album he speaks to
them using Hein doll's orange-eyed magic
where he can link his Consciousness
across the Galaxy we see Thor linking
with him as he did with Heimdall in
Ragnarok and into this cage Thor
realizes it is headed toward the shadow
realm and he flips back and notice now
that he has some black smudges on his
cape showing how Gore's Shadows were
beginning to eat away at him Thor
describes the shadow realm the
atmosphere there has a Darkness like no
other this is if color feels to tread
it's color we need
and the rainbow but hang on he moves
through shadows and he's going to the
shadow realm it seems like that's always
going to be the most powerful are you
thinking what I think you're thinking
I'm thinking
omnipotent City another detail from
Jason Aaron's God of Thunder Run
constructed by the Lords of the Dawn
with trimmings from the clay of creation
fired with the Embers of the first sun
and here a Thor name drops his favorite
Gods he says we can recruit raw Hercules
tumatoanga maybe and Zeus and yes he
buried Hercules in there setting up the
son of Zeus in the longtime rival to
Thor in the comics whose introduced
played by Brett Goldstein in the
post-credits scene ra of course is the
Egyptian sun god who did not show up in
Moon Knight tsuma toenga is Maori god of
war and hunting and Quetzalcoatl is the
Aztec creation deity depicted as a
feathered serpent Jane smashes her sink
as she recalls how her mother Elaine
also died of cancer so we got Elaine
Foster Meredith quill Maria Rambo what
is it with the moms of cosmically
powered MCU Heroes dying of cancer and
by the way the name Elaine might be a
Seinfeld reference because this movie's
working title was the big salad which
was reference to a Seinfeld episode by
the way Spider-Man No Way Holmes working
title was Serenity Now which was another
Seinfeld reference Thor promises that
his Guardian that the return with the
children but not for them to Feast on
suggesting the asgardians used to eat
kids at some point yikes they install a
Stormbreaker on one of the floating
Asgard tour boats this one named the
Egger Egger is the Norse god of the sea
and a big partier of the Marvel Comics
this boat also has a neon sign reading
cocktails and dreams a prop from the
1988 Tom Cruise movie Cocktail I like
how Stormbreaker cast this Rainbow
Bridge before the goat's feet that
disappears behind them and as always
love to see the bifrost as an actual
Bridge platform for people to walk on
and the chunks of this bridge are the
kind of glowing fiberglass look that the
bifrost bridge was back in Asgard and
they arrive in omnipotent City and it
looks a lot like it does in the comics
and notice how there are various
waterfalls just pouring down from higher
and higher tiers like an infinity pool
sneaking through an aqueduct and this
shimmering design looks a lot like a
more advanced version of Asgard
suggesting that one inspired the other
it's kind of like being more familiar
with Disney World and then visiting
Disneyland and realizing oh it's the
same thing it's just a more condensed
and cultier Jane brainstorms more
catchphrase options like eat this hammer
or check out my hammer but it's her
first bad guy Thor response never forget
you first meanwhile ax tries to cheer up
the other kids telling them about how
Thor Ford Stormbreaker from a dying star
we saw that in Infinity war and telling
them how he used that ax to cut off
thanos's head and end game meanwhile
Gore creepily just appears in this cage
and scares these kids away from the
whole idea of something being headed by
ripping off the head of his serpent
meanwhile the rest of the crew sneaks
into the gods meeting disguised as
emotion gods and there are some amazing
cameos of gods here there's a golden
dragon that looks a lot like the great
protector of talo from shung Chi there's
a giant eyeball there's bow the god of
dumplings he's actually voiced by Simona
paparelli wolf a long time Marvel
Studios team member Louis desposito's
assistant turn producer Valkyrie
mentions a god of magic a god of dreams
and a god of carpentry who is off screen
by day yeah implying that Jesus is MCU
Cannon and hangs out with Zeus we see
two celestials peering in from outside
the hall based on their appearances the
one on the left with the five eyes in
the antlered head is a mad Celestial
from a 2012 fantastic four-story line
when celestials tried to steal Reed
Richard's alternate reality viewer to
conquer the Multiverse and then on the
right that matches the design of a
Celestial Gardener from a 2013 uncanny
Avenger storyline involving the planting
of Life Seeds and death seeds and
planets korik spots an old Cronin God
who's also played by Tech with TTV and
mocap and I think my favorite detail of
this movie The Cronin God sits on a
throne of scissors like the iron throne
but Scissors because you know rock beat
scissors you don't need to be afraid
unless you're made of scissors just a
little rock paper says a joke for you
this is all part of a running rock paper
scissors gag starting in Ragnarok rock
where korg's uprisingly failed because
he didn't hand out enough paper leaflets
but Meek who is a scissor person
essentially was able to defeat sakarins
whom Drax previously referred to as
paper people their sightings of
sycophant gods and Dionysus the Greek
god of wine and partying played by Simon
Russell Beale there's accredited Aztec
god played by Nico Cortez perhaps it's
Quetzalcoatl whom Thor name dropped
earlier there is a credited Mayan God
credited as actor Iman J hajjiti that is
the giant figure who laughs from one of
the higher Thrones actress Sheila korewa
plays a Maori goddess presumably
tumatoinga actor Kuni Hashimoto plays
the Jade Mori God that's the giant
Samurai figure whom Thor has to step
over Nicole milinkovic plays the elsh
goddess or elk goddess the lady of Elke
being a limestone bus that was recovered
in Spain believed to be a carthaginian
goddess worshiped by the Punic iberians
Carmen Boone plays Minerva considered to
be the Roman version of the Greek Athena
now yeah eternals does make this all a
bit confusing since it wasn't apply that
the mythologies of Earth were inspired
by the eternals likethena but eternals
were revealed to be synthetic beings
made by the celestials to help them pop
planets presumably the eternals got
their names and identities from these
real Gods there's a crazy little fur God
played by Stephen Hunter a New Zealand
actor who played the dwarf bomber in The
Hobbit movies Clarissa Vicente plays
goddess of the Dead perhaps this entity
from Aztec mythology and sit in the road
directly in front of them is actor
akusia sabet who listed herself online
as Boston who is the wakandan Panther
deity aka the Egyptian feline goddess
she is not credited in this movie though
this could be an instance of an actor
listing on their resume based on what
they were told by casting directors and
wardrobe people without the producer
signing off on it the reality is that
actors don't have speaking lines in
movies or have some scripted action that
they have to do on camera or some
specific purpose in a scene they often
don't have to be credited but you know
what akosia you get yours you are bastet
and our headcanon and of course Zeus
appears played by Russell Crowe doing a
Greek accent he Wows the crowd with his
Thunderbolt tricks really the guy's most
obsessed with this year's orgy which is
very on brand for Zeus from Greek
mythology he's always turning into
animals and liking things Thor
represents himself to Zeus who shrugs
off the threat of Gore and uncovers
Thor's masquerade
oh you flipped too hard damn it except
of course the real thing we get some ass
notice how Thor has some tattoos on his
back R.I.P Loki with Loki's horned Crown
the word Brothers a broken heart and a
scroll with some runes on it but if you
look closely at that those ain't runes
it's actually names of people Thor has
lost the list reads mother father Hein
doll Loki Tony and Natasha yeah sorry
Vision you didn't make the cut along the
bottom of his back a banner that reads
rest in mischief and based off of what
we're seeing Loki doing in the TVA in
his second life our dude is getting into
plenty of Mischief Thor also said you
flicked too hard which reminds us of
Avengers endgame during the time ice
when Ant-Man presented and told
America's ass to flick him and if you
put the word flick in a comic book word
bubble and italicize it the yeah yeah we
we know what flick means Zeus says Gore
will never reach eternity and Valkyrie
tells Jane
eternity is a very powerful being at the
center of the universe it will grant the
desire of the first person who reaches
it and Jane asks so it's like a wishing
well well eternity is not really a
one-time Wishing Well in the comics but
eternity might have some reasons to
Grant one wish and peace out right now
in the MCU we'll talk about that a bit
later the guards have gold flesh and
they bleed gold make me wonder if they
might have been part of the Sovereign
from Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 but
later one of those Asgardian kids says
he's the midasian as in King Midas so
they might also be that I just love how
much taikwatichi is able to embrace the
golden bloodbath of this fight because
you know if the blood was red there is
no way they'd be allowed to do this in a
PG-13 movie Zeus Thunderbolts Korg but
luckily cronin's get crumbled all the
time so as long as their mouth stays
intact they are okay so that Cronin that
Thor smashed back in the dark world as
long as the mouth was intact he didn't
really kill him Thor catches the
Thunderbolt and Chucks it back through
Zeus Valkyrie ties cord's face to the
back of her braids so that the braids
give him a bit of a mustache
foreshadowing his future soulmate Cronin
with the handlebar mustache Dwayne on
the boat Thor and Jane sees the space
Dolphins whom Thor says mate for life in
packs of six there's that number six
coming back six OG Avengers six Infinity
Stones six dolphins in an orgy cork
sinks this Cronin courtship song that he
says his dad sing to each other and he
explains how cronin's hold hands over a
lava pit for a month and then produce a
new baby boy so all cronons are male
Korg references valkyrie's girlfriend
who died in their battle with hella that
we saw in the flashback in Ragnarok but
not really explored explicitly in that
movie script taikum TT shot that
flashback using Dynamic light technology
from the satellite lab and used the same
stunning enlightening effect for this
coming battle in the shadow realm so
valkyrie's coming fight for her at least
might be a bit triggering for her and
notice that when they fight there's a
light source that rapidly rotates around
the small planet creating these dizzying
Shadows which is interesting for
characters who are trying to fight the
Shadows like they don't know which the
moving Shadows are actual sentient
threats and when of them are just
natural on this terrain throughout this
act it's just visually haunting to see
this fight desaturate into monochrome
again because Shadows contain no light
and thus no color the conceptual
opposite of the rainbow that Thor and
Jane are bringing and I love how
throughout this sequence whenever they
use light sources like mjolnir or the
Thunderbolts color itself also emanates
from that glow there's a great gag here
with a goat boat smashing into the
planet which is a much smaller Moon than
anticipated a gag that we also saw in
Rick and Morty let's go down and check
her out
Oh I thought it was further away Gore
ensnares them in his shadow beasts
looking especially creepy with his
hollow eyes peering out from the
darkness Christian Bale's just
frighteningly demonic throughout this he
rasps
and looking ahead the ax being the
bringer of the buy for us makes a bit of
fitting terminology with Axel being the
future Heimdall Gore tells Thor love is
pain my daughter is the lucky one she
does not have to grow up in a world of
suffering and pain run by Wicked Gods
Choose Love call the ax if you think
about it he's setting up his own choice
to choose love capital L Love by the end
of this film Thor will be someone who
chooses love his adopted daughter in a
new reality where this guy's Gonna Get
Around by calling Axel his new Hein doll
Choose Love call the Axel this fight
ends with Valkyrie stabbed all of them
having to retreat in the bifrost but as
that exit move was a huge mistake by
Thor with hella it is also a mistake
here with Gore because he jumps into
this bifrost stream grabbing
Stormbreaker leaving Thor in the rest to
spiral off to some other location Jane
now separated from mjolnir reverts to
her weakened State leaving her body
unable to fight the cancer as mjolnir's
power-ups do to her in the Jason Aaron
Comics Thor gets the Thunderbolt from
Valkyrie and uses it to catch up with
Gore who is now taking the kids to this
eternity chamber it's interesting to see
it assembling into place I just think
this is what gorge travel looks like
from his perspective from the shadow
realm anytime he beams himself into a
place from his perspective it looks like
a room assembling around him now of
course these statues are all known
entities from Marvel Comics at the
center of course is a statue of Eternity
but if we go clockwise from that next is
Lady Death the skull face representation
of death in Marvel Lord it was to woo
her romantically that caused Thanos in
the comics to embark on his infinity
stone Crusade then Eon representing time
which is a gross bearded freak that no
joke Jim Starlin modeled on a stain on a
garbage bag that he saw on his sidewalk
then Infinity considered eternity's
sister believed to be associated with
the Infinity Stones on the other side of
the chamber though he was not visible in
the trailer footage is a green Celestial
this is the celestial form of the one
above all another ranking cosmic power
in the Marvel Universe then the Watcher
the multiversal overseer voiced by
Jeffrey Wright and what if and then
lastly The Living Tribunal the ultimate
the cosmic legal Authority with the
three faces of necessity equity and
revenge Bolivian tribunal just showed up
in Doctor Strange the Multiverse of
Madness and appeared as another severed
statue head showing up in the void in
Loki so these seven entities share the
chamber so they might be on equal Divine
status kind of checking and balancing
each other but it's also interesting
that they are tucked away together like
this in the center of the universe
almost like they've been exiled or
hidden or just forced into retirement
remember in what if the Watcher was
forbidden from intervening and perhaps
all these entities are bound by some
kind of non-intervention code unless
someone knocks at their door the fact
that bifrost can open a gate through
eternity statue to lead to eternity's
True Form in that realm suggested
similar door number two or door number
three could be opened into the Living
Tribunal statue to talk to them or into
the Watcher statue to talk to Jeffrey
Wright I cannot wait to see live action
Jeffrey Wright Watcher in the MCU Thor
empowers each of the Asgardian kids by
expanding Odin's worthiest charm we get
this great overhead shot that actually
looks like a tree branching out like
idrisil or like the roots of the Groot
arm Stormbreaker handle that we saw
earlier now among these kids in addition
to axel there is that my dassian kid but
also a lycan kid a wolf boy this Legend
is played by actor Khan Golder who
actually played young Arthur curry in
Aquaman I'm wondering if this lichen kit
might be Thor's illegitimate kid with
that Wolf Woman I don't know how long
ago it was but I think we should just
you know we should we should do a test
Jane ends up joining the fight using
Val's Pegasus and they're able to break
the necrosword and Jane summons the
fragments of mjolnir back to catch some
of the broken pieces of that sword with
it and then blast all of it with the
lightning again we see how Milner's
broken State gives it benefits that it
otherwise would not have Gore goes
through the open Eternity portal where
we see eternity's True Form they
actually pulled it off it's a starry
silhouette with the visitorship of bass
and it looks pretty cool eternity sits
at a zen-like state and interestingly
says nothing actually eternity seated
meditative pose mirrors Thor's
meditation at the start of this film
Thor's eyes in that moment opened like
the bluish skies and there may be a
metaphysical connection between him and
Eternity whose eyes stay closed in this
final scene so Gore awakens him and
those starry eyes glow brighter and
brighter I mean who knows maybe eternity
needed both Thor and Gore to find him at
the center of the universe so he turned
the activated both the Lord of Thunder
and the Lord of love so that eternity
could transform himself are we all
simply pawns on the chessboard of space
god seeking to give themselves makeovers
I mean if they do it in the Name of Love
who's to blame them now this watery
realm might be based on the dimension of
manifestations eternity's realm from the
90s Quasar Comics it actually looks a
lot like thanos's Soul realm except with
normal lighting I just love how
increasingly we're seeing more and more
Realms in addition to universes in the
MCU Natalie Portman said that they shot
one of these scenes at a Best Buy
parking lot I am guessing it was this
one and remember they described eternity
as a wishing well and now here in this
hopeful Sunny aquatic space the imagery
does evoke that of a wishing well Jane
encourages Gore to choose love and after
he gets an assurance that Thor will look
after his daughter he makes his one wish
to Eternity in a blinding light beams
from eternity's head and the camera
tilts down into the reflective water
where now beside Gore's body is a
reflection of a girl with eternity's
Starry form a girl now that we tilt up
is revealed to be his resurrected
daughter so love is another Cosmic
entity in the Marvel Comics because
pretty much every abstract concept is
actually a space God eventually in the
Marvel Comics love is considered on the
tier of characters like Order and Chaos
considered on a slightly lower tier than
eternity which makes sense because Korg
calls her born from eternity but in this
case it looks like eternity might have
transfigured its life force into a new
form the living embodiment of Love who
knows maybe what the boundaries of the
Multiverse eroding due to incursions
this being who sees time as a flat
circle felt that what the Multiverse
needs now more than a solid boundary is
the force that transcends all boundaries
an active force of compassion so in a
way eternity lives on but now the force
that binds the MCU together is love and
I kind of love that Jane tells Thor that
she finally came up with a catchphrase
and Whispers it in his ear we don't hear
what it was this mystery Whispers in a
way a nod to Jason Aaron's comics is
Nick Fury Whispers something in Thor's
ear to make him drop mill near and that
is what leads to Jane wielding it
sometime after we don't find out what
Fury said until much later we learn it
was the words Gore was right That Shook
Thor to his core and made him feel
unworthy now in this case I am going to
assume the whispered catchphrase is
something specific to the two of them
like I'll never forget my first time or
maybe something dumb like it's Hammer
Time the epilogue sequence shows a new
statue built to honor Jane the new
Asgard notice how the sculptors actually
made the effort to Chisel into mjolnir
to make sure that it is the cracks
version of the ulnir you have to wonder
if anyone from the ground level even
notices that detail but they took the
time to do it and I love it Valkyrie
trains the children of Asgard she's
wearing a jersey for the new Asgard
Kings and she is number one but SIV
trains Axel in private sessions so you
know we're gonna be calling that ax more
in the future Korg meets his love over a
lava pit Dwayne which come on has got to
be a nod to Dwayne The Rock Johnson I'll
fight anyone who says different Thor and
Gore's daughter love eat some breakfast
the same pancakes that a Thor made for
Jane but now he's making some time to
eat them with her the girl is reading
Jane's quantum physics book and Thor has
to uncloke her green Hood reminding us
of the reveal of Tony Stark's daughter
Morgan in endgame whom Tony had to
unmask from the helmet the first time we
saw her the two argue over her shoes
that leads to her shouting go to hell
demon and firing purple optic blasts
from her eyes who knows what this kid
can do this is like the new Jack Jack of
the MCU she's a space god she's an
embodiment of love I mean the sky's not
even the limit and as a kid who loves to
draw she draws a lady face a millionaire
and then they charge into this beach
battle to intervene in what looks like a
clearly overmatched Invasion by one
person to another we see their big jump
here that actually parallels the earlier
shot of Thor leaping alone to defend the
endogarians now he is no longer alone
Guns and Roses Sweet Child of Mine
returns and as I somehow predicted right
in my breakdown of the very first teaser
of this movie beyond the fitting lyrics
of praying for the thunder in the rain
to quietly Pass Me By The Sweet Child of
Mine of this song's title actually
refers to the Sweet Child Of Gore and
now this kid is the love to Thor's
Thunder that's everything I spot in this
movie and hey if you live in the San
Francisco Bay area you can actually come
see me do improv live with in-game's
improv every other Saturday night at 9pm
in the mission hit me up on Twitter or
Instagram for details at ee boss
following the Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
thank you
foreign
[Music]